A
CENTURY HERE IN CHICAGO.
YOU'VE GOT MURDERERS WHO ARE AT
HOME RIGHT NOW PEOPLE WERE
WAITING FOR TRIAL WITH
MONITORING DEVICES ON WHY ARE
THEY IN JAIL?
WHERE THESE PEOPLE BEING
PROSECUTED?
THE CLEARANCE RATE IS LOW WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO AND I'M TELLING YOU I
JUST WANT JUSTICE FOR MY LITTLE
BROTHER THAT'S ALL I WANT.
SO IF ANYONE IS LISTENING AND
YOU KNOW ANYTHING IF YOU DON'T
REACH OUT TO THE POLICE DME ON
INSTAGRAM AT GIANNO CALDWELL
REACH OUT TO ME ON FACEBOOK DO
WHATEVER WE JUST WANT TO SEE AN
END TO THIS SENSELESS VIOLENCE
BECAUSE A CONTINUOUS AND IF THE
CRIME POLICY CONTINUES AND NO
ONE, NO ONE CAN EVER BE SAFE IN
THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
>> Hannity: DEFEND, DISMANTLE,
AND OBEY ALL LAWS, LAST YEAR WAS
A RECORD AND WE ARE ON TRACK FOR
ANOTHER RECORD IN TERMS OF
MURDER RATES OF MANY BIG CITIES.
>> IF THE ON CUFF THE POLICE.
>> Hannity: WE FUND THEM.
>> THEY ARE DEMORALIZED THEY ARE
DEMORALIZED IN THIS CITY AND A
LOT OF OTHER MAJOR CITIES.
WE HAVE TO SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE IS A
BALANCE BETWEEN POLICE REFORM,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WITH THE
MAKE FOR THE PEOPLE FEEL SAFE IN
THAT POLICE ARE OPERATING IN A
PROPER WAY THAT THEY SHOULD.
WE NEED TO UNCOVER THE POLICE
AND LET THEM DO THEIR JOB.
>> Hannity: I CAN'T SAY IT ANY